entre les vacances de noël et les
vacances de février voici tout ce qu'on
doit savoir sur les nouvelles glisses
chaque année en effet il faut se tenir
au courant de ce qui se fait cette année
arrivée de la patinette sur neige ou
plus branché le snowscoot attention un f
bartoli pour se lancer à plus de 80
kilomètres heure sur cette espèce de
trottinette des neiges
une seule qualité est nécessaire s'est
posée le cerveau et y aller quand même
plus sérieusement cet engin est hybride
moitié ski moitié vélo la difficulté
c'est de savoir le piloter petite leçon
spéciale on enclenche le virage en
donnant la direction avec l'avant et on
balance le corps dans le virage et on
fait chasser l'arrière en aligne le tout
mais le plus spectaculaire c'est encore
le big air c'est à dire les sauts et les
figues ou amateurs taft news
depuis deux ans sa discipline ou prendre
l'ampleur en france ils sont déjà plus
de 4000 à la pratiquer